eight news now breaking news alert
six o'clock here on monday morning we
start with that breaking news at two
alarm fire in the near southeast valley
it happened very early this morning at a
strip mall near paradise and flamingo
let's get straight out to hector mejia
joining us live from the scene and
hector i understand now you have some
updates from clark county fire
they're still trying to figure out what
started this large fire when they
arrived they found large flames shooting
from the building so they had to bring
in just about 50 firefighters and take a
look at the damage at least one business
destroyed with more daylight
firefighters will start looking into
what started this large fire
thankfully no one was hurt but now we
have extensive damage here and this here
at the strip mall there are at least
eight or nine businesses one of them a
dry cleaners and it's going to be
devastating news not only for the shop
owner but also for dozens of customers
who will be showing up today on a monday
monday morning coming out here to
retrieve some of their belongings some
of their clothing only to find the strip
mall and the dry cleaners and the shape
i was talking with a couple of business
owners here earlier this morning about
an hour ago they were telling us they
had a really rough year with the
pandemic shutdowns they all look after
each other now they have to deal with
this and have to you know come out of
this and have to find the scene as soon
as they arrive so some of them are here
they are devastated with the scene
they're looking at right now but
thankfully no one was hurt we're
standing by for updates from the clark
county fire department we'll have an
update for you straight ahead in the
next half hour reporting live hector
mejia live local now